o da banda b am eu sou sortudo até
questões da universidade do havaí
geralmente dizem que os 178 infecções
essa opinião de vez em quando é que
estado de mesmo nome mas em surgiu é
porque nem eu sou professora do
engenheiro renato santos
os alunos têm portanto deixa de fora um
pouco o que se esperava que viesse falar
seria fundamental em tecnologia e janete
isso eu falo
deixem de tentar fazer muitas outras
pessoas serem pouco fora das minhas
águas não falar com a tecnologia em e no
fantástico desafio nós vamos fazer
os novos temas novas do futuro das
representadas todas também de temas mas
sobre o que podemos ou não fazer
o técnico e por que algumas coisas são
ou não são feitas já hoje estamos a
falar do fundo de mudanças são tão
significativas como o que aconteceu em
termos de questões já é com deixa de
fazer uma pergunta muito simples é todos
vocês têm telemóvel com certeza que você
já era um computador já cruzaram a
questão entra a informação o
processamento da informação cruzaram a
fronteira com a parte publicações
os jogos fazem isso naturalmente 15
quem é quem nesta sala tem um espaço com
aquilo que é desculpa não vejo muitas
pessoas votem sim vai cortar o tempo
fica mais pra quê
pronto a grande maioria então e das
pessoas daqui inscrevem vai ter gente já
vai quem é que já fez um post hoje são
propriedades aqui o conjunto algarvio de
especialistas no assunto é o que vou
tentar falar que é um povo que é quem
for mas há outros
nós podemos olhar a informação em termos
da cidade e eu não vou falar de coisas
como
o cenário principal o próximo passo é
colocar a sensores em todos os nossos
dispositivos nos frigoríficos no futebol
embora os pais não conseguem província
também assinados nos sensores de ruim
dos sensores do tráfego e sensores de
poluição sensores de perigo da radiação
ultra violeta não foi nada lhe tudo isso
somente envolve a um custo é resolveu
mentir um vaso na colocação de sensores
e e estamos em portugal
vamos falar de coisas pouco não ser
feitas já hoje com muito menos
aliás por falar em custo eu vi com mário
com a corda vai da união européia com
separaram que fez a vida toda com o
dispositivo de um custo muito elevado
eu acho que vou usar uma coisa baixo
custo é ver a situação é mesma coisa
eu o youtube vou falar não é nada do
outro mundo
escolhi açúcar vai ficar assim a pensar
não é ensinado muito enfrenta isso eu
fico satisfeito com o resultado da festa
eu não vou fazer uma coisa muito mal
estamos em aveiro pensar grande e tentar
ajudar nessa hora que vou tentar fazer é
um conjunto 4 e ao uso da propriedade
como um conceito da educação informação
e vou correr o ganso suspenso montillo
devem ter usado no moldes 30 mil em uma
pessoa pelas ruínas não é para usar isso
como o o ciclista ou capturar a
informação
então é que vai entrar na cidade velha
ao interessado a vai-vai o que ela seja
ampla entrada sua imediata também tenho
informação podem ver aqui eu não sei
estou à frente mas enfim podem ver aqui
sobre a informação é do segmento básicas
sobre a cidade
temos mandato terminará esta informação
todos vós encontrava a informação que é
tem alguma informação do tráfego
a única diferença é que isso quer dizer
aí agora eu tenho com um ambiente
integrado no qual essa informação
automaticamente disponibilizado com que
não andará estou a passar enfrenta o
estica do lado esquerdo tem eu tenho
universidade de brasília george mais
umas fotografias documentos são as
fotografias de colegas meus que estão
entre 4 na universidade continuará
enfrentando tudo isso eu posso ter hoje
em dia eu tô passada junto ao hospital e
agora começa a ter uma ou duas coisas já
não é tão fácil de obter enfrenta no
parto
nós temos um posto de abastecimento
elétrico como estaria acontecendo um
livre sobre a informação de que
e teve que é esta informação próprio ira
utilizará não sabia precisar ser a
alimentava é uma coisa que não sei se
repararam mas naquela imagem estava a
informação de quanto é bom que estavam a
ser usados naquele momento e isso eu já
posso usar eu posso escolher isso porque
consigo a carteira a qual é o consumo de
energia está a ser feito até o momento
e com base nisso está popular devido
pela lbr está a ser usado como já posso
querer
temos um grupo mais fácil fazer a curva
temos um hospital a um hospital em curva
e agora estamos a chegar ã aquela para
mover por favor desculpa
isto é é assim todos nós vamos lá ver ok
alguém acredita que isto é só passar por
lá neste momento e isso eu não sei se é
possível aqui na região e isso é
possível
temos uma imagem da fotografia que está
com essa nesta rua o anjo com as pessoas
vão saber compreender qual é o problema
bom e eu acho que estava equivocado eu
sou quem não tem muita tendência a falar
que a gente possa 0 para o entendo e é
isso que é da uefa já foi usada
o que nós podemos fazer a e portanto eu
quero os talentos nem eu deixei mudar um
caminho é minha apresentação
não no sentido que nós podemos fazer a
mas nós poderíamos fazer e eu vou
continuar a manter uma idéia do baixo
custo de não fazer grandes mudanças em
todas as cidades mas a nossa escala quem
tentar ver o que poderíamos obter
assinada ou informação que ela ia estar
já tudo agregada na ponta das nossas
mãos por exemplo usar o vídeo então
desta forma com este conceito eu
gostaria tanto tarde a agora eu quanto o
próximo já vai da informação do estado
em obras até consigo ver quais são os
sentidos em que possam andar
perfeitamento hoje em dia tem a questão
das rotas e tenho a informação porque é
que a obra está a decorrer
continuando ultimamente até seria capaz
de ver as imagens atuais mas eu sei que
consegui conseguir ser inscrito tem à
frente o parque consigo ver aqui agora a
informação de uma forma de ferro por
exemplo olharem para trás
vocês vão continuar a ver as fotografias
das pessoas ao estado o governo caso da
universidade
mas há uma diferença muito grande aquilo
que eu mostrei um caso onde o cidadão as
pessoas estavam matriculados
aquilo que eu estou mostrar quem são as
pessoas que tornam parte agora isto é eu
tenho condições de saber quais os meus
amigos estão o parque naquele momento
tem condições de saber quais os parcos
dos campeões de tênis estão a ser usado
em condições eles possam jogar ténis de
instrumento ou não e dizer isso porque
por causa do tempo por zagallo ainda
está no caso da energia também tem
informação sobre o parque
a informação está na câmara isso exige
que ele não consiga fazer isso neste
momento a única coisa que eu precisava
era dessa informação financeira
informação e por inclusive associar
todas as questões da discussão pública
aí essa informação eo verificado foi ou
não foi modificado
continuando a enfrentar o parque tem um
conservatório olha o conservatório
separarem temos eventos atuais e tem
alguma coisa que lhes horário em que seu
pai tem algumas pequenas frente muito
porque não é nosso cuidado
eu nunca sei o horário do meu filho não
há nada que me impeça de o pdt horário
explicar a opção imediatamente perceba o
horário do meu filho por um sistema sabe
que sou eu
sabe eu estava tripulado sabe como o
horário do mesmo horário fixo mas ele já
não têm aulas hoje eu pegava essa
partida seria portanto eu tô mal com
isso
continuando a dar tapas na traseira do
curso pelo que sabemos o que vamos
entrar avisa que vai dar à série a ver
seus filhos das primárias para frente e
eu tenho certeza que ele ia começar a
haver grandes questões do que se passa
pelo menos movimento ele ficava lento
movimento unificado ao alvo era ea cinco
do pavimento danificado eu poderia
inclusive obter informação ontem que
estamos gratos à cidade da praia
continuando a minha viagem por esta
sociedade aberta é eu não vou não vou
continuar com isto muito mais tempo
vamos ver por exemplo assim o símbolo do
buraco onde estava o desempenho dos
outros problemas aí
agora vou passar pelo primeiro
restaurante
ao contrário da enchente deve ser
possível esquema e portanto não posso
receber o novo ministro tem um conjunto
de informação tira tem envolvimento dos
meus amigos gostam dos talentos têm o
movimento o menu do dia que ela troca
principal é mostrar essa piada
fraseologia neste prazo fazendo mas
depois tem outra informação importante
na pública
tem uma coisa por exemplo o tempo médio
que o leva serviços naquela história e
tem outra coisa mais interessante o
tempo que deus pra se quiser serviço
naquele momento
estas informações não são fornecidos
pelos brancos
mas eu poderia tê las e vou já falar um
pouco sobre isso
finalmente saiu
eu tenho um afeto tem um viés é eo eo
museu eu não vou falar para os estados
que estão mais dois casos tenham buscado
informação tá estruturada duas formas
eu tenho informação de um longo caso
como o edifício em si
você é muito difícil não é
os horários das missas no caso o oco é
só problema do outro mas também tem
informação transitório
por exemplo quantas pessoas estão usando
é que o momento está muito cheio
por exemplo hoje é a noite dos museus e
portanto eu gostar aberta hoje à noite
ou por exemplo quem é o sacerdote foi
oficiada missa hoje posso agradar não dá
pra bahia sabe a diferença
bom isto não é tão difícil de fazer
foi inventar grandes coisas simplesmente
a informação toda na cidade no mesmo
sítio
com uma diferença antes da prisa e
olhando pra isto eu diria que só três
grandes diferenças o primeiro objetivo é
que o discurso para o que acontece agora
em tempo real foi toda a informação da
mãe a informar a quanto é que toda a
gente a fazer isto estava em um momento
difícil em publicar essa informação por
exemplo das obras
respeito mas é uma vantagem que era uma
mudança do paradigma acontecer quem
estava a ser servido pelos serviços mas
sim que sentiu efetivamente empenhado
envolvidas no processo
a vantagem é claro que as empresas
tenham que ver vantagem
texto de condicionalismos para poder
andar pra frente para curar é que o foi
a única coisa que foi ministro da
fazenda que é o piso com base nestas
coisas estão aqui traz isso foi feito
com base naquela coisa que ela está o
meu smartphone que eu falei foi andar
com elas todos técnicas podemos fazer
muito mais coisas e esse é o ponto
principal é é participação do cidadão é
o filho não se cria em que a informação
exista está no sport é contribuir pra
ela e é isso que torna o evento mas nada
é ou não é em termos de visibilidade e
formação em termos de empenhamento e de
criação de uma grande unidade da palavra
pouco tempo uma palavra só quatro final
eu tenho que agradecer a muita gente do
meu grupo de investigação porque embora
isso tenha sido apresentada desta forma
é realmente um resultado muito trabalho
a muita gente
em particular eu gostava de vencer o são
paulo atacar ea cara que está lá atrás
de deus a passar o vídeo da pena né
e eu disse que era o passo final eu
estava determinada uma palavra final e
não é uma palavra optimismo com
mantiqueira é uma palavra que eu gostava
mais força pois a tecnologia já permite
fazer qualquer coisa sagrada
mesmo com que nos investimento podemos
mudar essa triste e violenta cidade que
o tempo passa a ser é seu filho e sesi
imagine estar a informação que pretendem
e com a mãe ela se você souber responder
talvez
província funcionado muito obrigado